so so maybe in case there's somebody
watching at
home we're waiting for another member of
our committee to show up because at the
moment we have four out of nine so we
we're not quite at at good enough
strength yes representative
wer oh can you do that at the last
minute or I've always been told you need
like a whole week or something you
know if we don't exact he could just sit
down yeah I suppose
okay but in any case it we like delayed
here
all
right all right we're going to get
started because um the sponsor of the
second bill at 10:30 has a really tight
schedule so um and we have the and we
have now a
quorum so thank you
um uh to representative Hua so um let's
get started on uh House Bill 194 and
I'll recognize the sponsor
representative
ger thank you Mr chairman members of the
the committee uh so uh you know my idea
thinking about also working with a lot
of Educators in chesher County over the
years and and seeing a lot of the great
work they do particularly for National
History day uh I thought it would be
really great if there was just one place
uh on a State website that that you
could go and you could see the list of
all of the public monuments in the state
if you wanted to go visit all of the war
memorials for example in the state they
would all be listed there you could see
where they were uh and so that was just
the impetus for the bill is the way that
we use monuments for Education right and
if if we want young people in New
Hampshire to really feel rooted and
grounded in the state uh and to
appreciate the rich uh history and the
cultures of the state to stay here or to
come back here after college uh this is
obviously an issue that we have for the
state in terms of a lot of young people
who go out of state for school and
unfortunately don't come back I think if
they feel rooted in the history and and
the cultures of our state I think that
that would help them see New Hampshire
as a place that where they do want to be
in the long run and raise their
families so I submitted the bill I was a
newbie I had been elected but I had uh
not been seated you know when I
submitted this bill in the first place
and I sent it to the wrong Department uh
I am as you said a historian so I think
about archives you archive things you
know you archive whatever so I had to go
to the archives that was the wrong place
uh and uh they don't have a position
where somebody would would do that work
uh and so then I worked with director
Wilson who will be speaking after me at
the division of historical resources to
amend the bill to make sure number one
it was going to the right place and
number two so that the amendment was
written specifically in a way that would
allow the division to do the work
without additional resources that it
fits within the resources that they
currently have so the amendment was
written as I said specifically with the
director to uh serve those purposes
right so what it would be is a very
simple uh list the kind of qualifying uh
important qualifying phrase in the bill
itself is that it is a list of publicly
maintained monuments there was kind of a
question of well what's a monument and
then that can get a little sticky in
this case it is publicly maintained and
what that means is that every town right
has a list of The Monuments it maintains
so this is a finite list of objects in
the state so uh the division as director
Wilson will testify can reach out to
localities they will send in the
information and it will all be put on a
list that is then put up uh for for
anyone in the state to to access uh and
you know I could dream about someday
maybe we could we could find some uh
grant money from the ne or some other
source that would allow us to kind of
build it out as an educational tool but
I think this is an important step as you
said for teachers for students and also
for anybody uh in the state who wants to
be able to visit something like all of
our war memorials there's one place
where you could find all of that
information so
that is a a really quick overview as I
said the director will testify to the
ability of the division to perform the
work without any additional
resources all right thank you
representative does the committee have
any
questions no well I'll ask one why
not
um do you see this list as just a a a
Bare Bones kind of spreadsheet kind of
list you know the name of the thing the
place where it is is maybe the year it
was created or something like that um or
is this going to be more of a an more
interesting website that has photos and
the descriptions and stuff like
that thank you for the question to begin
with it'll be a very Bare Bones uh list
again the purpose was to to have it be
something that the department division
can do without additional resources and
the and the director could speak to what
exactly that involves my understanding
is it's just a straightforward list uh
and I do want to also add which I should
have in my introductory remarks that uh
the reason why it is a bill is because
to in order to have the division update
the list every 10 years as the Director
will testify that has to be in statute
uh so that is the part of the bill that
requires a change to the statute but as
as far as I understand it it will begin
as a pretty straightforward list without
many bells or
whistles thank you any other questions
yes representative grass I I just have a
brief comment would you believe that uh
one of the towns I worked with we
actually did this with some of our
historic structures in the community
it's part of our master plan we went out
and actually Geo referenced the location
and then tagged photos to it and we the
Geo referencing was actually done by um
um Eagle Scout um that went out and
actually did that work we'd assign him
to a neighborhood and go out and you
know just go down the street and every
time you come to one of these address is
just hit the button and it worked out
reasonably well I would have no trouble
believing that at
all thank you representative so do we
need to do the pink card thing would
that help you or is yeah I mean I think
usually yeah Mike could you find a a
small stack and so represent German fill
one out
please yeah all right well anyways uh
thank you so um direct thank you
director Wilson did you want to weigh in
oh here we
go yeah go ahead thank you so the
representative basically explained all
of my testimony um which I thank him for
um so we um I simply would assign some
oh I'm sorry say who you are for the
record absolutely my apologies uh I'm
I'm Ben Wilson I'm the director of the
division of historical Resources
Department of Natural and cultural
resources um so I would simply assign
somebody in our office as I do with
other projects um to write a letter or
send an email to town administrators and
historical societies within towns and
cities um as well as the state because
the state maintains monuments for
instance out on the State House lawn so
I would send a letter to commissioner
Arling house um and as the
representative mentioned every uh entity
has a list of the things that they ask
their local dpws to to maintain and uh
um so much like having a u a local
circuit Rider Eagle Scout um do that
work um we wouldn't have to employ
anybody to go out and physically um find
these locations because they are they
are maintained publicly maintained and
we wouldn't expand beyond that unless
there was actual funding um to make make
that
happen so I'm happy to answer questions
any
questions yes representative people
thank you so just to just to sort of
restate the situation the bill was um
introduced to require the creation of
this listing it has a fiscal note
of couple hundred, doll give or take but
you're saying now that that money isn't
needed to put the this bill into action
if it passes that's correct so when the
bill was originally assigned to the
Secretary of State's office um they
don't employ people that you know do
these kinds of things um our division we
have multiple lists dozens of lists of
national register uh locations state
Register locations historic Highway
markers you name it um and they're
simple lists they're not they're not U
they don't have long descriptions in
some case no photos and that sort of
thing so naturally the Secretary of
State's office put in a fiscal note of I
think it was 117,000 or somewhere around
around that and that makes sense because
they were going to have to hire and pay
benefits to somebody over the course of
a year or two um we won't have to do
that um as amended we don't see any
fiscal um demands on our division or
Department thank you um how about to put
it on the website will you need doit or
or is that just something you do by
yourself pretty easily I'm I'm glad you
asked it's a great question we just
launched a brand new website for The
Division I want you all to go see it um
on uh January 10th last week and um we
would just simply create a page um as we
do with other new information that we're
adding to the website there's no C great
any other
questions no yeah yes I sorry
representative thank you Mr chair for
indulging me what's the
website um good
question if you go to the if you go to
our um um Department of Natural cultural
resources um website um nh.gov um you'll
find our division as one of the five
divisions under that and your division
is again sorry your division is again is
the uh division of of historical
resources thank you yeah and I'm sorry I
don't have that exact address
but yes represent sorry how quickly do
you think you could do
this um another good question um it
depends on how quickly um our letters
are answered or emails are answered um I
would expect it would take a
year thank
you any other questions all right thank
you very much is there anyone else here
who wishes to weigh in an House Bill
194 all right seeing none uh shall
we yeah I guess we're not exacting today
right so yeah so we'll we'll just recess
for 11 minutes and be here very promptly
at
[Laughter]
10:30
we'll open up the work session on House
Bill 318
FN relative to bail Commissioners and
making Appropriations to the judicial
branch representative Lynn I see you on
the list
here
it's it's your
bill I
[Laughter]
think you of the history yeah thank
you so thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee um I'm Representative Bob
Linn from Windam and when you say I'm
give you the history I'm I'm I'm not
sure I have enough time to do that and
and I'm not sure frankly that I
intelligently could do that anymore
because there have been so many changes
uh that have happened and I I mean I
really I I I have to extend you know
hearty congratulations to Chairman Roy
from Criminal Justice for being able to
get everybody together to get um to get
the bail reform sort of uh through uh on
a policy level the only thing that I um
uh raise a a question about is is simply
from a purely
Financial perspective um is there I hope
that this committee will look carefully
at whether there is really a
need for 15
magistrates while you're also going to
have all of the bail Commissioners I
mean one of one of the things that I
remember way back when this first
started was there was some
discussion um uh about whether there
should be whether uh the the uh judicial
branch should hire magist should should
they be uh approved to hire magistrates
which who would have sort of limited
responsibilities or should there simply
be an increase in the number of Judges
who would be able to have you know would
be able to do everything so to speak
within the within the uh uh the realm of
the judicial branch um my personal sense
was it made more sense to hire judges
but I can completely understand that you
know there's a good argument on the
other side to to hire magistrates
instead but the one point that I would
make is at at the time that that was
originally discussed the idea I believe
uh then there was the talk was at the
time of 15 magistrates uh but the idea
at least at at that time was that the
magistrates would replace the bail Comm
Commissioners as I understand it now the
magistrates would there would be 15
magistrates but the bail Commissioners
would also remain um and so I my only
question is it you
know unless things have changed really
really dramatically and I'm willing to
I'm assumed in the four years since I've
left the judicial branch I'm sure there
have been changes I don't have any doubt
about that particularly I left before Co
so I'm sure there have been changes but
I have to say I have to say that I do
question the idea of the need for 15
magistrates right now while you also
have you know keep all the bail
Commissioners if the thought was that
bail Commissioners as they retire or
something will not be replaced or will
be replaced with magistrates that might
make perfect sense to do that but I just
ask I just asked this committee to look
carefully at the at the money part of
this uh and other than that I as I say I
commend chairman Roy for his efforts and
been able to get this together I it
seems like um uh you know on balance
this is a really good compromise was
able to get everyone together and I uh
very much support the
bill and other than that I'm happy to
take
questions as a good representative knows
we try to state of financial matters but
this is kind of an unruly Bunch so we
often Venture into I do remember from my
my one term on finance yes I remember we
learned all our lessons from
representative Smith who was sitting in
the back
[Laughter]
there anywhere there questions for the
good representative yes representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question so I mentioned
this earlier to you but I want to do it
in session um we have three bills that
all seem to be on the same sort of topic
of bail and what happens to people
between arrest and trial that's this
bill the one that follows Senate Bill
252 and there's also Senate Bill 249
which also mentions magistrates would it
make sense to to combine all these
things into one sort of comprehensive
bill so that so that the governor can
see a a full plan or is this more of a a
Chinese menu kind of situation where
where you could take all three or some
two or some one and it would all you
know it would be they're all
independent you know I I would defer to
Chairman Roy on this because I I um I
have an interest in this area but I'm
not on the criminal justice committee
and I know they have really shephered
this um just as a you know for as a from
a from a practical standpoint I would
say that if unless there are other
considerations it would seem to me that
it would make sense to give the governor
one bill but maybe there are other
considerations and that's something that
uh chairman Roy I think could address
all right thank you I'll ask him the
same
question further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
you chairman Roy nice to see
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm here today to discuss the
uh two bail bills you have in front of
you um I guess I'll start by addressing
some of the concerns we just heard with
because they're probably the most
expensive piece is the magistrate system
the magistrate system it it I can
understand um the former Chief Justice's
concerns with u regard to what he saw
when he was there in the need firm
there's a couple is issues one is the
magistrates are doing more than just
bail they are going to be doing certain
ministerial duties that will free up
Circuit Court Justices by holding
hearings and such as needed as dictated
by the Chief
Justice they are also the number 15 was
arrived at by you have one per County
their duties will be to and there's five
extras to cover
vacations and other workload type
issues their duties will be to supervise
all the bail clerks excuse me bail
Commissioners within their counties to
ensure that they are trained per the
statute that we have put in that was one
of the main concerns we he heard that
they weren't getting the proper training
they
needed um they are to ensure that they
are properly staffed and coveraged
because we heard from the jails in the
prison that often times they could wait
8 n hours to get a bail commissioner
they would go through the list and then
start through the list again and people
would sit there and wait to get out of
jail because there weren't bail
Commissioners we had bail Commissioners
who just resigned and sent an email to
somebody nobody knew they were gone um
so the it was kind of chaos is what we
heard in the realm of bail
Commissioners so there's another issue
with regard to bail Commissioners as
well with regard to their status no
one's quite sure if they're employees or
if they're not not the court treats them
as sort of
contractors but if you read the IRS
rules they
are they dictate their place of
employment their time of employment and
how much money they get that kind of
sounds like an employee to the IRS so
the court right now is juggling and
dealing with what they're going to do
about that so if they are faced with
having to phase out Bail Commissioners
they'll be in a world of hurt if they
don't have somebody there
so that's that's another look at that so
the the magistrates are there to cover a
wide range of things also in the statute
that we just
wrote the at the suggestion of the
Senate and we concurred there are
certain very serious crimes that we are
not going to allow bail Commissioners to
rule on those will have to be a
magistrate or a
judge we also said that someone can't be
held more than 24 hours with without
somebody ruling on their bail ability
well that means somebody has to work on
a weekend that will be the job of the
magistrates we conferred with the court
over several meetings they didn't feel
it would be logistically possible to
have a judge do it because they would
have to open the court to do that and to
do that to open the court you have to
have a clerk and you have to have other
employees who are members of a union so
now you have to impact bargain their
contract and it becomes a very expensive
Quagmire
with the what we figured out is with the
magistrates they can conduct these
remotely they are highly trained um and
they will be hearing the more serious
crimes over the weekend so I think I've
laid out pretty much what the
magistrates are going to do in a
justification for the number in their
job um and with that I'm happy to take
any other questions because there's so
much in the bill I could spend an hour
going over I'd like to also add I
appreciate um representative Lynn giving
me credit crit for this but I want to
make it clear I couldn't have done it
without my Democratic colleagues um
representative here Gite representative
Muse were key to making sure this all
came
together represent Maguire thank you Mr
chairman thank you for coming um so if
we look at our fiscal note it it's looks
like about a
3.16 million ongoing cost and my
understanding of magistrates would be
about 2 million or so of that do you
know what the other million is is being
used for well this goes to your question
about combining bills so if the one if
the fiscal note is on the bill that has
the bail Commissioners getting paid that
could be the other one mon million-ish
um what we discovered was the where the
currently the statute is that whoever
gets bailed has to pay the bail
commissioner when they pay him who knows
it's not enforced so we had bail
commissioner is telling us about 40% of
the time they don't get paid at all we
had one bail commissioner come and
testify he was owed
$52,000 in over a two-year period from
bails he had done he gets called out at
3: in the morning goes out bails
somebody out he doesn't get paid for it
40% of the time it's a
freebie that's not how should we be we
should be treating people who do this
key service for us because if the bail
Commissioners all quit tomorrow our
criminal justice system will come to a
screeching halt so what we came up with
was okay the court is going to pay the
bail Commissioners their fee and the
court can recover the money from the
defendant the way it is now the bail
commissioner if he really wanted to get
paid would actually have to sue a
defendant to get his money and you know
the CH it would cost them money to
actually prosecute that case so with the
Court's ability to order fines and
payments they are well better placed to
recoup that money than the bail
Commissioners were so in the bill we put
the power for the court and they're
allowed to give up to a year to pay the
money
$50 you don't have it right now that's
fine you've got a whole year to pass as
long as they get it back into the
coffers and it goes back into their
money hopefully that will offset a large
portion of that extra $2
million further question thank you so uh
when you say that they're not getting
paid they're not getting paid the $40 is
that is that that's all they do get paid
that's that's it okay got yeah they have
no salary or stip in anything can you
give us any um statistics in general how
many bail Commissioners are there how
many cases do they deal with you know
roughly I can I can give you first we
can talk about the bail
Commissioners currently we think there's
about a hundred the fact that I have to
say think is indicative of a problem um
no one knows for sure hence we need this
supervisory
the judges are supposed to do it if
you've seen their court case loads they
just don't have time it's this is such a
a ministerial type of thing um so no
one's really sure how many we guess
about a 100 that give or take um their
cases I can't really say they're they're
they're you know they deal with every
single arrest so we're looking in the
thousands uh per year so it's it's quite
significant every single person who's
arrested in Hampshire unless it's a a
warrant that says no bail is entitled to
bail and the vast vast majority are
entitled to bail so the bail
Commissioners are called on every single
arrest so one more um you heard uh
representative Lynn um say that he
thinks 15 is too
many um and you yourself said that
they're going to do their work
online and certain um certain uh
counties are very small compared to
others right I've heard it said that all
of Coos is smaller than Portsmouth for
example right so um since it's online
could maybe one handle multiple counties
and therefore we don't need all 15 um
I'm not sure if I said it online if I
did I misspoke there's no mandate that
it be online they're just going to
handle them on the weekend so they may
very well have to go out to do it in
person um to look at the case File the
one of the problems we have in New
Hampshire and I tried to address an in
this and it was a bridge too far is our
inter electronic Communication System
between the branches the judicial
executive as far as law enforcement goes
is horrific so bail Commissioners when
they go to do a bail they rely on the
police department to give them a printed
copy of a defendant's record so because
it's illegal to transmit it through
email so they kind of have to do go in
person most of the time and the problem
is some of our to your point some of our
distant counties up there our friends
they don't even have a computer terminal
in their Police Department to print the
record so they have to go to a local
County Jail they'll print the criminal
record then they'll bring it back to
show the bail commissioner so it gets
quite quite complicated whether or not
we could shave off one or two is open
for debate as far as how many um this
was the number that I was given we
looked at the justification we felt that
that that logistic wise not financially
but policy logistic wise it made sense
whether that ends up being too many in
the as but we all know that once a
position's there the position's there so
um I I would say
that it's possible that they don't need
50 and they may could get by with 12 um
but I I just I would hesitate to do it
and then have to come back at this again
and say we're short but that's
fortunately your decision to
make representative huitt did you have a
question yeah I am I'm on the other end
of
this I was a district court judge for
quite a few years uh the
the the features of this whole problem
involve money and they involve
politics so you haven't got a an easy
job
um the theory is that bail Commissioners
were created for the purpose of
facilitating uh compliance with the with
the
Constitution uh they were as a general
rule not very well educated in their job
although they they were they were
citizens who had a general working
knowledge of the government
that sort of thing um but getting them
out and working was a a difficult thing
uh I think I made a record one one year
of having issue set bail in the middle
of the night uh for somebody in
Keen about a dozen
times this isn't something that's going
to end easily because number one as you
said uh the bail Commissioners are not
paid on a regular or
a a a basis which you can identify
because they have they collect from the
from the from the defendant well let's
face it uh a lot of the bail
Commissioners do most of their business
at
night because in the daytime people can
go to the courthouse and they can go
know all kinds of things can be done but
in the middle of the night uh there are
a lot of crimes committed in New
Hampshire and each one of those crimes
if the if the perpetrator is
caught and that sets off the bail
commissioner situation because the
Constitution says how long you can hang
on to
them and that's something that's kind of
you know
working
along maybe some of them may get out a
little bit
longer than one would like sometimes in
terms of days and I've heard of a couple
of cases in terms of weeks that they got
got held before they could post bail and
that was perfectly logical because they
didn't have any money with which to post
bail if they couldn't post bail they
couldn't get out
so and I I've watched this happen since
I've since I've happily
retired i' s watched this happen I talk
with I have a lot of friends who B
Commissioners uh because I dealt with
all the bail Commissioners in bnna
County because Leon was the only place
that had a
court that could administer this sort of
thing and not all the courts have judges
who are interested in this stuff
either and it's a it's a difficult
situation but law is not an easy thing
to
understand and for somebody who's a you
know auto mechanic or who's a a bank
teller or something in the middle of the
night to understand the complexities of
a say a a federal offense as opposed to
a state offense and all that stuff is
very difficult and I hope that the the
committee and I hope that the
legislature takes a long hard look at
this and doesn't fall in the Trap
of
funding more
more more small businesses within the
court system and within the state
because that's that's going to cost a
lot of money
eventually and there's no need for it if
it's done
right so so I wish you all the fck in
the
world thank you cuz I sat with this and
listened to people and listened to
listen to the fail Commissioners
complain and some of them run off of the
mouth for a long time about their their
sad situation and you couldn't sit there
and listen to it and not agree that's
the trouble you couldn't say I yeah full
of
blone because they weren't full of blone
they were absolutely right we were WR
wrong and the people were wrong the most
were the local governments who refused
to participate in the funding of all of
this
yeah
so I wish you all the luck in the world
and there are a lot of questions uh a
lot of questions that need to be
answered before you can get through it
yeah um to your to your point with
regard to the training uh or their their
experience to be able to make
discernments about um complicated issues
regarding bail even to um questions
regarding you know fugitive from justice
warrants and things of this nature it's
very complex that's why we mandated
before they come on board they get 40
hours of training um and they get an
annual training on any updates in the
law so the the days of you know here
here you go um go get them are gone the
they will be trained and that's another
reason that the magistrates had to have
um the position was classified as it was
they have to be educated they have to be
educated in the law what we were
concerned about is you know a bunch of
retired police Chiefs looking to add to
their retirement no we want hopefully
attorneys and so we needed a position
classified at that rank that would that
would support that kind of salary um so
it it it is very key that we have
intelligent people making these
decisions not only to ensure defendants
um get their fair fair hearing but to
also make sure that we're not exposing
the state state to liability for
lawsuits because bad decisions were made
by untrained people in the middle of the
night are further questions
representative wer followed by
representative evil thank
you uh Mr chairman the idea of having 15
you talked about one per County and
obviously that so is this a job we show
up whenever the Court's in session
rather than a bail commissioner that's
sitting at home unless he gets called oh
no this is a report for work job report
for work whenever the court is in
session and I would imagine the the you
know and I tried not to micromanage the
the the a judicial branch so but it's a
full-time job my my understanding is
they're looking at having them on a
rotating schedule so that you know some
will work weekends this week or for a
month and then the next one that type of
thing because that's why you need more
than just one per County because you
don't want one working every weekend all
year long so I believe that they're
going to look into rotating it and and
but it's a show up for work at your
office every every working day type of
job so we start with Hillsboro having
two counties two County um courts anyway
yeah right so that that already brings
it to 11 yeah yeah thank you some like
you like the representative said some of
them you know that you go up there you
might have one that part-time but other
other areas make up for that
so yeah since um thank you for all your
work on this it's just been an
unbelievable process I know I just want
to make sure I have it right in the
notes so you said that um there's a
magistrate for every County plus five to
fill in for okay and then the number or
the recommended number you got from the
judicial branch are they the ones that
provided the yes they are um we what we
did is we looked at the we talked to the
judicial branch we talked to the the
Attorney General the Chiefs of police
everybody in the jails and we looked at
you know how many cases how often are
they called how many weekend calls and
um we submitted that to the judicial
branch and say look what do you need to
be able to do this um and we they were
given two options would you need um to
open the courts on the weekends we
pursued that a little bit and we
realized that was not the road to go
down we went back and said okay let's
look at the magistrates again we know
that that position was already floated
several years ago in a concept of
replacing bail Commissioners um that
bill didn't go anywhere at the time
because you cannot replace over a
hundred we should have about 130 bail
Commissioners with 15 people um it's
just not feasible they it just wouldn't
happen um but you can augment them and
maybe limit the number shrink the number
of bail Commissioners eventually once
you have trained people in place but the
yeah the 15 we got from the court and
they based it on the coverage that they
would have to do and anticipating
vacations and a rotating shift so that
they didn't have to work every weekend
cuz if you're arrested on Saturday you
have to get bailed on a Sunday so it's
not just Saturdays they have to work
Saturday Sundays if it's a if it's
Christmas if it's a holiday the those
magistrates have to be available because
no one can be held for more than 24
hours on that list of crimes so someone
has to be available 24/7 365 days a year
throughout the entire
State just ask a follow
um okay well I think that's really
important testimony because it sounds to
me like you did a massive amount of
research uh uh to to ultimately to give
to the judicial branch and for them to
come up with the number that's needed
it's not like something that just kind
of evolved yeah yeah this was definitely
not pulled out of pulled out of the air
type of thing I I gave them parameters
what I thought we needed and what I
would ask be asking of the judicial
branch and they said this is what we can
do and this is what we need whether or
not that ends up being you know a little
too
much you guys know better than I how how
how the branches request money and how
they cushion I mean do they assume
you're going to cut some anyway and ads
I don't know I'm a policy guy you're
money so I don't I don't know I know the
policy is very sound um the cost I don't
know so I have just a couple of
questions so I served as a bail
commissioner in the Milford district
court for a number of years and at the
time the Local District Court Judge
appointed you and there was to a
representative ht's comment I was
probably not well educated to take the
position but I see here it says uh 15
highly qualified magistrates what are
those qualifications do you know that
makes them highly qualified yes we um
originally I I wanted to put in there
they had to be an attorney and another
branch of government weigh in and said
um well if you do that it's going to
cause problems as far as if if we can't
fill the positions it doesn't let us
pick someone for example with a master's
degree or or someone with a significant
experience so I said
well so the human resources people said
that it's better to classify the job at
a at a job classification level and then
the criteria are kind of built into
those so we're talking about people with
at least Advanced degrees is what I was
told um so it's not going to be you know
a retired police Sergeant um coming in
there unless he has degrees that would
that would actually qualify for him for
that step that they've qualified the
position at again this is kind of
something where I'm going to lean on you
to say I I I don't I don't really know
how the step systems work and the salary
systems work I I I would assume that you
guys are experts in that and you might
be a tell me yeah we'll try but uh with
the difficulty we're having finding
qualified people for anything exactly
was there any thought given to like is
how soon would you get the 15 qualified
magistrates is it going to take a couple
of years or are there people lining up
at your door banging on it to say we're
qualified to do this new role well one
of the when I when I came out and said
listen I want these to be attorneys they
went well you realize we can't get
attorneys to fill our regular jobs right
now never mind someone who's going to
work on the weekends so um that's why
they said look you have to make it if
you limit us to just attorneys we may
not be able to fill these for years um
and we might never get the 15 they said
it's better to qualify it at a step that
we could say this person has to be
qualified and educated but doesn't
necessarily have to be a member of the
bar so that's what we agreed to as a
compromise so they said it could take
about a year hopefully and and that's
another good point though when we say 15
they might never get 15 um they at the
salary it's paying even though it's good
you could still go to a firm or
somewhere else and make much more money
so you are going to be looking at people
that are you know interested in that
type of work and that's what they want
to do it's not going to be someone in
there trying to to make a career of
it thank you are there further questions
for chairman
Roy yes
Professor thank let me ask you the
question I I asked representative Lynn
at the end are you familiar with this
bill the next one Senate Bill 252 and
Senate Bill 249 are these all
independent or they somehow connected so
um there was a lot of debate on how we
should best do this at the beginning
should we wake make one Omnibus Bill and
and our feeling was well first of all um
the the temperature of the house is we
don't like omnus Bill
um and each of these things does a very
detailed thing but yet they can't work
without the other one so if you pull the
magistrates out the bail changes with
regard to what people can be held and
not held falls apart so the whole thing
is connected but for the purposes of
getting it through the house so it
didn't look like we were trying to pack
a bill in the middle of the night it we
said let's keep it clear keep it
transparent keep it separate should you
decide or the Senate decide to Cobble it
together for the governor I have no
objections but to pull something aside
say we're not going to do this piece the
whole thing falls
apart you may so if we did decide to go
that way with a single Bill yes would it
make sense that it it sounds like these
are significant changes from what the
Senate sent us yes so it might make
sense to do that with a house bill
rather than the Senate bill because if
you get sent back a Senate bill it would
just be Committee of conference yes but
if you send them a house bill then they
have a full hearing and the whole works
right we looked at that as okay maybe if
we send if we make if we make one thing
and put it in the Senate bill they can
just vote to Concur and that piece of
the bill will go through but then
they're going to hold hearings on the
other stuff anyway so um I I would leave
it to your wisdom whether you think
that's a better strategic move at this
point um just keep in mind I believe
that our bail reform bills are not just
house bills one of the set up bills as
part of it so I'm not sure how you would
amend that all into one bill if that's
even logistically possible and I believe
they just passed another bail bill so I
when I saw that I just almost
quit thank you represented Sweeney AG
grassy you have any
questions thank you thank you very much
for your time represent sure so um just
from a hiring standpoint if you didn't
get all the magistrates that you needed
which is as likely as not might they
share some of the um burden between
counties or would you still think that
there would just be a magistrate Per
County I would think they would do
whatever we told them to do and whatever
staff we give them to do it um that
being said um that's what they told me
they needed and they thought um I know
that if you reduce the number of
magistrates it's not going to kill the
the policy behind the bill it may make
it tougher to implement um I just I'm in
a position I don't want to give anyone
any excuses to say well it's not working
because you didn't do this or we asked
for that and you didn't give it to us I
am I've I've dealt with our friends
across the other side um uh and the
other body and um you know it got pretty
heated at our last Committee of
conference and there were a lot of
fingers pointed no more we're done we we
we did what you asked um we did what the
court asked we did what the law
enforcement asked we got everyone so I
don't want want anyone coming back later
saying well it would have worked but for
so that's that's where I'm out on
that well I know I speak for everyone
here we're glad you are where you are
with chairing the criminal justice
committee do a great job I really
appreciate that I'm Honor by thank you
chairman yeah thank you members of the
committee further questions on anyone
anyone out there on 318 that would like
to
speak seeing none will close the work
session on 318
representative McGuire are you planning
to bring an amendment forward to maybe
consolidate or you have some ideas or it
I it's way too early so it's thank you
for the question I figured that's Wasing
around in your mind so what's going on
in my mind is that um all of the bills
that we have that spend money and and
we're likely to want to pass them I'm
tending to think we should not exact
them or or finalize them until
March uh because by then we'll know
what's going on in other divisions with
other bills we'll have a total you know
of how much everything is going to cost
and what our resources are and stuff
like that so I think we have some time
to let these percolate and and think
about and and so on I mean there's some
bills like the first one had no fiscal
impact that that we could pass pretty
quickly I would think and maybe there's
a few others that are just obvious Nos
and we itl pretty quickly but for things
like this where almost certainly we want
to pass
something I would think we have some
time to to to to think about them that's
my thought no it's good point you okay
with that Mr
chairman yes you will
note division two I have a bill to say
this um money that all went went stuck
into the education trust fund we notice
that because they ignored
our uh Amendment and just put in their
own and put in far more money than even
the governor's budget had and so here's
200 million that's just can't be used
for anything else but of course every
every school district's asking for a new
building because of that money sitting
out there so that hopefully that will
come and will pass and we'll move that
money from educ trust fund to
general fund and then we'll have more
flexibility as you say we'll know later
on in the session do we have that extra
money plus we're going to have meetings
today with with the
U the court system about this all these
monies that they're paying out for the
victims of the sununu litigation which
the judge and I have had discussions it
does seem it's excessive we gave them a
budget we wish they'd stay within it so
we're going to have those discussions
here both today and within um
fiscal but we may have to come up with
some more money for that but anyway yeah
I'm hoping that that will pass and then
things like this that we'll be seeing in
the meantime we'll get all these other
bills spending money so we want to know
where we've got money to spend if
any thanks Ken so moving it's 11 o'clock
or there abouts um Senate bill
252 relative to the release of
defendants pending trial Etc is someone
here to speak to that I saw you were on
the list I
um yeah if there's nobody else
wishing though I see the Secretary of
State here and I'm wondering maybe he
didn't get the message about one of the
other bills that
was coming
up no it is
not so there was a there was apparently
there was a problem that came to us and
it should have gone to the policy
committee or something like that but I
can explain yeah represent MCU yes so so
represent Maguire I'll just explain so
um we only see things in division as a
second committee when when we have a
bill that's brand new like this one we
have we have a full committee public
hearing first and and it so we made a
mistake and we didn't realize that it
was new and not arriving via some other
committee so that's the problem so we'll
be in the big room at some point yeah
there should have been a notice sorry
you didn't get it but yeah went out last
week but thank you I figured you must it
was nice to see you I know you're very
busy or should be busy next week right
yeah week yeah take care
chairman
Roy it's nice to see all of you again
thank you very much um representative
Terry Roy Rockingham 31 uh chairman
criminal justice on on the bill I uh
before you now um I would just reiterate
everything I said five minutes ago um
they're all Interlink they're all tied
together um and I just I think it would
be better if you've looked at the bill
if you had certain questions I'd be
happy to try and answer them for
you represent
Maguire thank you do we have a new
fiscal note yes we do uhuh dated 160
gotta yeah I haven't really
looked all right so um this says that
we're going to be spending 1.7 million
in the first year is that to create some
kind of uh computer system or something
like that um if I could just for a
second because I haven't seen a new FAL
not I just need to look at
it Mr
hofman that amount comes from the
Appropriations in the bill at the end of
the
bill
Okay this may be um with regard to the
monitoring I think electronic monitoring
um based on what I'm seeing in the
fiscal note the one of the pieces of the
bill um that we we struggled with was
dealing with people who were
rearrested um as a policy issue what was
happening um in many communities and
many communities were very upset about
is you had people that would be arrested
and and they're not people that were
arrested for for for horrific crimes
they were what we kind of coined as
nuisance crimes these are your
disorderly person your trespass your uh
petty theft your shoplifting and they'd
get bailed on personal recognizance and
a day later or two days later they'd get
picked up again and again personal
recognizance because these are not um
these are classy misdemeanors some of
them don't even have jail time if you
get found guilty so we had a revolving
door so we put in there that okay you
get two bites that Apple if you get
arrested again after you're out on bail
you are held um and you can explain to
the judge why you cannot seem to refrain
from Criminal Behavior but one of them
was for people who committed domestic
violence um people who are accused of
domestic violence are entitled to bail
like everybody else but for safety
purposes as which was also part of the
policy of the spills to enhance Public
Safety we insisted that people that who
are released on bail for violating a
protective order be given electronic
monitor
that can be monitored by um someone the
court assigns to see that that person
stays away from the victim and they're
not where they're supposed to be and
keep in mind this is just people who are
violated a protective order not who just
got arrested on the original domestic
so naturally it is going to have a
fiscal no I would I would say that if
you look at the statutes the ability to
use electronic monitoring has been in
our statutes for years it's just never
been implemented and part of the reason
is cuz we never gave the courts the
money and said do it we just said you
can use electronic monitoring well
that's great but if you don't fund it
and tell them do it it's just worthless
words on a piece of paper so we've
actually putting teeth into it and we
want it to be implemented just about
every other state in the country uses
these um we're our our computer and
electronics in New Hampshire is is so
behind the times we're working on 80s
level stuff here um and it's really sad
when you know that there's places in
this state that don't even have computer
terminals to run somebody's record at a
police station one of the worst things
that I'd call to your attention that is
that you can and some of that money goes
to this is that you can be arrested
right now and conquered for an assault
and battery happens in front of a police
officer he arrest you you get
bailed and conditions of bail don't get
arrested again stay out of you could
drive to Portsmith and get arrest
arrested again that same day the next
day the bail commissioner and everyone
there thinks it's your first arrest
because that's not recorded it's not
shared between the so you could
theoretically string up four or five
arrests before someone finally realize
hey wait a minute you're on bail from an
arrest three arrests ago um which is
very sad in this day and age we have the
capabilities to do this we just have to
tell them to do it and give them the
money to do it so that's that's about
all I can say about that so further
question yeah thank you so so would this
electronic monitoring just be for
domestic violence or would they use get
would it make sense to use it on more
things because presumably that saves
money from not having somebody overnight
in a County Jail it does and and they're
authorized to use it for whatever they
see fit it's in the statute that they
can and we're only mandating it if
you're going to let someone out who's
who's violated an order already you have
to use it um I would hope that once they
actually have the system in front of
them they say hey we can use this on a
lot more things but what I can't do is
go and say you're going to use on this
offense this offense I I don't want to
the judges are judges for a reason so I
let them I just want them aware that
they have this tool now and that they
will hopefully um use it but we're
mandating it for that one thing I think
otherwise it would be too complex to
micromanage it do one more do you have
an idea of numbers like how many um
people are on bail for domestic violence
and and roughly how long or do they are
they in that condition um sadly there's
going to be several hundred a year who
are arrested for violating restraining
orders um so if they're going to be
entitled The Bear you could be looking
at several hundred of these whether it's
at one time I I don't really have it and
that's another problem if you want to go
to the courts and get statistics be
prepared to drive because you every
single court is a silo there's no system
where you can go and say how many
domestic arrests were there in the state
of last year no you start driving which
is horribly sad in this day and age
again we are so far behind technology
wise
thank I thought we put in a bill last
time you when I talked did did in the
Senate killed the money remember
yeah they said if you don't give me
these is that your foreign
government no
comment uh Mr Mr Hoffman is it possible
for you and or Melissa to put something
together for us with all the bills that
are dealing with this uh bill issue and
the cost of same kind of following in
what representative Maguire talked about
you know combining them but at least
give us an idea of collectively the
costs of all the different bail
bills yes I can work on that
thanks it'll take a
while we Mr hofen and Melissa very good
at this stuff yeah are there further
questions
for Mr Roy no all right thanks Terry for
this thank you again good to
see you folks out there just interested
in what we're doing or you have anything
to
add all
right all right seeing no more uh folks
here on 252 we'll close the work session
and we'll come back and visit these
areas in a month or two
amen I can assure you representative
Maguire will be knocking on your
door can I just ask uh representative
Roy was there someone in the judicial
branch in particular that's
yeah
Aaron she she's new but very good would
the division like her to come before us
so we can talk some of these questions
through yeah that's what I was thinking
was that the job that Richard head had
yes I was surprised he got
hired
um Mr Hoffman could you check with the
judicial branch and see if we could get
someone over here to talk to us on these
bail issues in the next couple weeks so
sometime when you have more yeah exactly
yeah okay
thanks all right thanks
everybody thano I
appreciate but division one had most of
the bills we got yeah
um Jeff St is of is retiring and his
party is right now in the up Walker
house if anyone cares to yes I
will oh ar e r i
n c
g
yeah